[Musique]
prêt pour en débattre
nous sommes avec eric à boké et
sénateurs pcf du nord philippe herlin
économise bonsoir à tous les deux merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
on l'a dit un collectif de scientifiques
médecins économistes syndicalistes et
responsables des ong exigent donc cette
levée un des brevets sur les vaccins
dans le but d'accroître de toute urgence
la production mondiale des négociations
sont d'ailleurs en cours
l oms à la demande de l'inde et
l'afrique du sud mais est-ce réaliste
cette demande philippe herlin tout ça
c'est typiquement communiste étatiste
parce qu'une fois une fois qu'on a
récupéré une fois qu'on ne prend pas en
l'hypothèse une fois qu'on l'a récupéré
et ce n'est pas qu'on a mis ses brevets
dans le public on fait quoi on construit
des usines pour faire des vaccins mais
ça va pas ça prend trop de temps donc il
faut réquisitionner les entreprises donc
on donc on va on va et attiser les
entreprises et puis ensuite on va les
faire marcher au bâton pour qu'elles
produisent des portes et produisent des
vaccins mais ça c'est un modèle qui est
complètement une économie dirigiste
communiste et l'histoire a montré que ça
marchait pas du tout ce mode de
fonctionnement
donc c'est une est profondément stupide
il faut au contraire jouer sur la
concurrence le fait qu'ils aient
plusieurs en doc les skis effet
plusieurs bassins c'est une bonne chose
et c était en concurrence et plusieurs
en sortie des vaccins maintenant on a
chacun peut les choisir
chaque pays et même chaque chaque
personne peut choisir tel vaccin plutôt
que telle autre
et donc on est dans la quête de liberté
et de concurrence qui est nettement plus
efficace pour la recherche pour la
concurrence par les prix parce que si
s'il ya un vaccin qui était dix fois
plus cher fait sauter ben miller band a
aucun donc le fait qu'ils aient
plusieurs vaccins ça tire les prix vers
le bas c'est une très bonne chose et du
monde en profite
et voilà on est dans un système qui
fonctionne bien qui est efficient et
mettre ça dans le même public maintenant
ce serait se serait l'idée la plus
stupide d'affaires bonbons dans la
situation actuelle
alors éric bocquet je sens qu'il va
il avait un petit bond une idée
communiste une concurrence saine
éric bocquet malgré tout la collectivité
avant tout selon vous l'intérêt général
avant que le vaccin comme les
médicaments n'est pas une marchandise
comme l'autre c'est même pas une
marchandise
seul atome est dans le domaine public
effectivement je voudrais rappeler
l'anecdote de ce biologiste américain
jonah ce souk dans les années 60 celui
qui a découvert le vaccin contre la
poliomyélite
interrogé un jour sur une un plateau de
télévision on lui a demandé à qui serait
attribué le brevet et il a eu cette
réponse absolument formidable c'était
pas un communiste le gars il a dit ben
écoutez le brevet sera remis au peuple
est ce que le soleil doit faire l'objet
d'un brevet nous sommes en face d'une
épidémie historique jamais le monde a
été confronté à cette situation tous les
états sont percutés toutes les économies
toutes les nations d'ailleurs la demande
qui a été déposée par l'afrique du sud
et l'inde a été soutenue par les 100
pays les plus pauvres du monde
noront est très loin d'une idée entre
guillemets communiste ça n'a rien à voir
il s'agit de l'intérêt général est ce
que le médicament est ce que le vaccin
doit être une marchandise
il faut absolument lever les brevets
mettre en place la licence d'office ça
existe dans le code de la santé est
dictée par le ms
il faut que les états poussent dans ce
sens il faut que le politique dans le
bon sens du terme reprennent la main sur
les affaires du monde
alors justement les politiques qu'ont
les écoule 1 c2 on les écoute pardon
c'est de votre bord éric bocquet je vous
propose d'écouter ce qu'on peut enfin le
premier secrétaire national de votre
parti le pcf fabien roussel à lille
comme dans toutes les régions de france
nous sommes mobilisés pour demander la
levée des brevets sur les vaccins contre
la copie 19
même s'il doit prendre une décision ces
jours ci la france doit soutenir la
demande de l'afrique du sud est de
l'inde
la première partie on l'a compris vous
êtes pour la levée de ces brevets mais
ce que dit en gros fabien roussel c'est
que la france doit porter ce combat est
d'ailleurs l'appel de paris sa porte
bien son nom
était lancée aujourd'hui c'est pas un
petit peu gonflé là j'aurais fait
l'avocat du diable mais pour la france
qui n'a produit aucun vaccin est facile
de demander à d'autres pays peut-être
qu'ils ont réussi qui ont investi des
milliards justement de produire et de
partage et surtout ce vaccin phillip r
là on imagine que ces pays vont pas
forcément bien réagir bah oui mais oui
c'était encore plus rien nous on n'a
même pas le vaccin parce que on a un
mauvais sont pas suffisamment
performantes notamment parce qu elle
sera écrasée par des impôts la france a
le taux de prêt obligatoire le plus
élevé du monde on est un
on est un pays pas communisme est
socialiste et on envoie les haltes à
tous les jours avec les désastres les 10
nations et qui est notamment le fait
qu'on n'est pas qu'on n'a même pas des
gars de trouver un vaccin donc la voie
c'est pas deux évidemment si c'est très
facile d'aller d'aller piquer le banc
que les brevets y catégorie tête effet
pas aux entreprises étrangères pour le
ramener en france mais s'est passé de
façon là pour adresser l'économie bon
voilà quoi
et puis pour obtenir cela où son intérêt
général l'intérêt général quand il
définit uniquement par l'état moi je
venais fini moi je considère que
l'intérêt général et les citoyens ont le
droit de donner leur avis donc il faut
défendre la liberté d'expression et la
liberté de décision la liberté de
choisir plusieurs vaccins parce que si
si on si on revient modèle de monsieur
mba ce moment là il y aura un vaccin
promu par l'état et on n'a aucun choix
moi ça me plaît pas moi je veux avoir le
choix enfin personnellement champlain
maxime et sorcières que les gens
devraient avoir le choix de se faire
vacciner voilà et le brevet c'est
quelque chose de nécessaire pour le
développement de l'industrie
et puis il faut savoir aussi que le
brevet c'est pas éternel le brevet au
bout d'un moment ils tombent dans le
domaine public et à ce moment là il ya
soit des génériques est ce qui fait que
la plupart des maladies aujourd'hui
peuvent être soignés par des génériques
c'est à dire des brevets qui justement
sont tombés dans le domaine public donc
donc c'est quelque chose de très simple
tout à fait normal il faut pas qu'une
entreprise bénéficie éternellement de
son brevet donc c'est normal que ça
retombe dans le domaine public et
s'oblige d'entreprises va trouver
d'autres vagues d'autres médicaments et
d'autres vaccins
donc ça c'est un mécanisme de
concurrence très simple voilà donc
donc la plupart des médicaments en fait
sont aujourd'hui des des génériques
et puis là les entreprises ont fait des
efforts énormes en très peu de temps
pour sortir des vaccins est normal
qu'ils puissent toucher des revenus pour
le stress me payer les chercheurs qui
ont travaillé quoi parce que si on leur
pique le le les brevets maintenant avons
pu avoir de ressources donc comment
comment ils vont payer l'essence et moi
ça on a compris vide et philippe herlin
éric bocquet sur cet argument il faut
bien payer les chercheurs et justement
que peut-être ses laboratoires qui n'ont
pas toujours bonne presse et on peut
comprendre les raisons il faut bien
justement qui se rémunèrent de façon à
peut-être trouvé voilà d'autres vaccins
et puis d'ailleurs pas que contre le coc
vide mais contre le cancer vous fait
quoi de seine ce dernier argument
écoutez moi je vais quand même rappeler
ici que le crédit d'impôt recherche en
france qui représente une dépense de 6
milliards d'euros par an dont un groupe
comme sanofi a bénéficié par centaines
de millions d'euros
et l'on constate que sur la période le
groupe sanofi envisage de supprimer 400
postes de chercheurs et a fait le choix
de rémunérer grassement les dividendes
des actionnaires
quand je parlais tout à l'heure d'une
marchandise c'est ça que j'avais en tête
est-ce qu'on est en face ici d'un
produit marchand comme des chaussettes
et du dentifrice
on est en phase avec ce que tout le
monde attend ça fait un an qu'on est
dans la pandémie la seule issue pour sa
télé cette crise économique sociale et
maintenant psychologique c'est la
vaccination sur un plan très très large
d'où l'intérêt de lever les brevets nous
avons les capacités en france de
produire ce vaccin
je constate malheureusement aujourd'hui
aucun vaccin est produit dans ce pays le
pays de pasteur c'est quand même
absolument sidérant l'espagne en
produits la belgique en produits
l'allemagne en produit le royaume uni en
produit est d'ailleurs réalisé une
performance exceptionnelle en matière de
vaccination s'est pas fatal il n'y a
aucune fatalité à ça donc il ya de
l'argent public qui a servi aussi à
aider les groupes pharmaceutiques
français qui aujourd'hui ne sont pas au
rendez vous de la vaccination
votre réponse un philippe herlin
pourquoi la france ne produit pas
deux vaccins comme ça je suis d'accord
que sanofi j'ai des partenaires l'office
est un échec énorme faim le fait que la
france est le premier vaccin ce n'est
pas énorme mais la solution c'est pas
des les piquets des brevets aux
entreprises étrangères à la solution
c'est de faire en sorte que l'économie
française soit plus performante
ça s'inscrit dans une tendance générale
est la désindustrialisation à une fuite
des cerveaux aussi et ça c'est des
problèmes aux français que l'on connaît
et qui tiennent notamment au fait qui
est qu'il ya trop de charges qui pèsent
sur de crise alors lé cic c'est trop
libéral et antilibéral mais quand même
parce qu'on arrive en voilà de ceux qui
veulent la levée de ce vaccin c'est
d'augmenter aussi la production est ce
qu'il y aurait pas des chances
d'augmenter la production de ce vaccin
parce que là on est en train de parler
de voile est de partager le brevet enfin
en attendant on n'arrive pas à produire
assez su si tous les pays se mettent
justement à à produire parce que les
brevets sont libérés est ce qu'on ne
l'aura pas ça va bénéficier à tous les
états finalement moi je crois en action
n'a pas ces vaccins c'est parce qu'on a
voulu c'est parce qu'elle venait de
mâcon a absolument voulu passer par
l'union européenne qui est une bourreau
craties copenhague efficace et qui s'est
complètement plantée dans l'achat des
vaccins il y aura mes gueux nique la
france s'occupe d'acheter des vaccins
et comme l'a fait l'angleterre justement
et on en aurait beaucoup plus si on
pourra vacciner beaucoup plus de monde
voilà c'est ça la cause du problème
aujourd'hui en france on n'a pris aucune
responsabilité on s'est reposé sur la
bureaucratie européenne
eh ben on voit le résultat éric bocquet
est ce que vous n'allez pas trop vite
avec votre proposition père score on l'a
vu tous les vaccins ne font pas de
consensus en c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire aujourd'hui d'astrazeneca et
suspendu en norvège au danemark en
islande alors pas en france pour
l'instant votre demande europe et cfc
quoi de de lever tous les brevets ou
d'enlever seulement un certain mais
l'urgence de l'urgence est hélas
l'urgence l'urgence et les sanitaires
aujourd'hui monsieur rien que je
respecte
me parle économie est confiant
ans moi je parle santé vie et humain
qu'est ce que vous voulez on a deux
logiques en face mais c'est tout à fait
créateur de ce qui est en train de se
passer
on a servi des dividendes chez sanofi et
on a supprimé des bois c'est le
chercheur est-ce qu'on n'est pas en
train de payer aussi c'est soit
stratégique de ce grand groupe
pharmaceutique
quand on est quand même sixième
puissance économique du monde on n'est
pas un pays de second rang on n'est pas
les meilleurs du monde n'aurait des
capacités intellectuelles industriels et
scientifiques de produire les choses que
moi je n'accepte pas que la france ait
cette situation aujourd'hui il ne doit
rien la fatalité conséquent ce choix
économique
je me suis fière la partage je respecte
mais je ne je ne partage pas promet
encore aujourd'hui on est dans une
situation d'urgence il faut vacciner les
gens sur une grande échelle
la question c'est celle là alors en tout
cas les français sont favorables à cette
idée regardez le résultat de ce sondage
aux femmes france 70% c'est beaucoup
estiment que le partage devrait être
obligatoire oxfam qui dit que ça n'a
aucun sens de maintenir un contrôle
exclusif de quelques grandes entreprises
permettre ce type sur la production
philippe herlin votre réponse l'oxfam
aucun sens de maintenir le contrôle
exclusif sur quelques entreprises de
production pour dire ça peut passer de
dire qu'on est à côté de l'humain quand
l'adversaire lui coûter de l'argent
parce que c'est pas le capitalisme et le
libéralisme au permis développer
l'économie et un système de santé
performant en europe et en occident on
va la première chose par rapport aux
sondages et oxfam bon ça que les
sondages sont un peu déterminé par celui
qui de commandes hawks avaient une
officine écologistes et gauchistes donc
c'est pas le résultat n'est pas étonnant
ensuite que les français qu'une partie
des français sa part investi les bat on
leur présente ça comme ce sera mieux et
moins cher donc a priori ils disent oui
mais je pense que si on leur expliquait
vraiment les tenants et les aboutissants
le fait qu'il faut investir pour trouver
des vaccins que ça tombe pas du ciel
et puis que si l'état contre toute la
production comme d'ailleurs régime
communiste eh ben ça marche pas du tout
et puis aux filles au final dans les
régimes communistes y avait que des
pénuries donc et comme la france est
socialiste mais bon on a régime de
pénurie voilà donc c'est pour ça qu'il
faut sortir de cette logique est allé
car plus de liberté économique et des
libertés en général et
bocquet le mot de la fin mozafar écouté
hier j'ai une rencontre il ya au sénat
il ya des choses qui arrivent avec
l'ambassadeur de cuba qui nous
expliquait qu'il y avait cinq vaccin
actuellement en analyse à cuba pour
lancer la campagne de vaccination vous
avez le droit d'avoir les idées que vous
avez que je ne partage pas mais
franchement le débat est un peu
caricatural encore une fois l'urgence
c'est de déployer la vaccination à
grande échelle
quand d'autres pays qui ne sont pas des
pays communistes le fonds est prêt
devrait s'inspirer de leur stratégie
aussi on lâche que je voulais dire mais
les pumas unam modèle ça c'est sûr ça
c'est sûr cuba est un modèle mais c'est
sûr merci à environ vous mettra pas
d'accord c'était pas de bus c'était un
face à face et d'affronter donc des
idées différentes merci en tous les cas
tous les deux éric bocquet et philippe
even avoir été avec nous